who have
a victor in the house with maurice that
is alex lenderman
not just a victor he drew his first
three games including one against wesley
soh so he is tied for second place at
the moment with wesley with fabi
potentially with lanier depending on how
he does
alex congratulations welcome to the show
the tournament so far you've been sort
of quiet on our radar just playing good
chess how do you feel about your form
this breakthrough victory especially
puts your tournament in a very nice
light yeah i think my form is good
actually i think i had a couple of
missed opportunities in some earlier
rounds um
where if i had
let's say um
been more active in terms of playing
like i made some rookie mistakes such as
playing
a little too automatically at a couple
of moments
um you know and certainly the first two
games i thought were winnable at some
point especially the first one you know
i had a very good chance but you know
i'm doing my best and that's behind us
now and at least i feel like my form is
closer to my us open for not my world
open four which is good you play lanier
in the first round right so you play
linear to a draw wesley to a draw now a
victory and
really so far a great result tell us
about this game where do you think your
opponent went wrong
you know i have no idea it was a very
tense game it it did look like i got a
pretty good position at some point um
yeah so
this knight f1 f4 plane i didn't really
expect
um and and in general this queen f4 move
it was kind of interesting i'm not
well i mean the first queen a4 was made
sense but the second time he played
queen f4
was a little surprising i
i'm wondering if there's something he
didn't like about
castles instead of queen a4
because uh
yeah castle's e6 yeah instead of
yeah rook city yeah here instead of
queen e4 if he castled i wasn't sure
why it's so bad i mean e6 95 i thought
at some point
or rookie one first i mean
well i mean maybe he didn't like
something about the position and that's
why q4 he was kind of silently offering
me a draw to go bishop d7 so i figured
if he didn't go for that maybe he's
trying to get me to make a draw
so i thought maybe i'm already doing
pretty well
always nice when your opponent suggests
a draw in a simple position i mean i
don't know for sure if he definitely but
it seemed like he was unhappy with the
way the opening went because he played
the same thing as he did against jeffrey
and i played this new idea takes in
queen c7 which i think there are only a
couple of games in the database and he
started thinking right away so it seemed
like he was
not so comfortable
how did you come to the idea of queen c7
alex because we were like in this
position
and a uscf chess coach would say to
their charges bring out your knights
bring out your bishops delay the queen
but you came up with queen
why well i thought queen c7 is a pretty
logical move because we're basically
playing a reversed carl spot yeah and in
the carl spot and the queen's gambler
declined white very often plays queen c2
you know bishop g4 e6 bishop d6 so it's
actually pretty standard okay i'm down
to tempo but it actually makes sense and
if i go knight c6 the point is he has
some bishop b595 so i wanted to not show
my hand queen c7 is the one move that's
very flexible it's a move i might need
no matter what while if i'm going knight
c6 right away i'm not sure and also i
don't know yet if i'm putting my bishop
on f5 or g4 because in some lines the
bishop was coming to a five and of
course you know i at some point when i
saw that nerdsyki played this against
jeffrey i just went to eat and i let the
computer run in that position and i came
up with this idea and then i saw wow
nobody played it so you know might as
well give it a try
always nice when the engine can do the
work for you here right okay it's not a
position where the engine is helpful but
put it that way the engine didn't mind
it you know it's giving zeros everywhere
of course but it was the type of zeros
where i thought i'll get my opponent
office prep you know and also i get a
solid good position where i play
something
reverse something that i'm pretty
comfortable with
um yeah and later on i don't know maybe
i'm sure his position was fine at some
point but i guess
i don't know i guess i could
it was very critical because i couldn't
really calculate all the way through if
i can take an a3 or not but i i didn't
see a reputation so i went for it so i
guess he shouldn't have allowed it
somehow the moment right here uh
you did actually once this bishop got
buried that just looks maybe he's
supposed to play h4 instead of h3 i was
wondering if that was playable because
even if i get
h4 he's going to play some rook h3 at
some point so i wasn't really sure like
somehow
the point of h5 inclusion was so that
he can't go bishop e1 in some cases to
defend c3 that's why it was very
important to include those two moves in
i thought so i thought h5 was very very
interesting i'm not sure if it's the
best but at least
um
what do you mean he can't oh you mean if
you play h4 and forces bishop to the h2
square yes because if i play bishop a3
right away instead of
you know h5 h4 instead of including h5
h4 and stuff like that i thought in some
lines you can go bishop e1 right my
bishop might be
i mean i wasn't sure it was very
difficult to calculate all that but i
just thought i have to trust myself here
all right so now you did grab the pawn
industrious barn to grab for sure hit
hit it and then played a5 and it looks
like you get out
and he doesn't seem to have any play
here yeah i mean i didn't see i looked
at a lot of lines for him but i just
didn't see anything for him and i guess
there's just nothing there so then i'm
up a pawn and then after that
it seemed like from that moment point on
his strategy being became completely
different he was trying to play very
fast and kind of almost out hustled me
and trying to go for initiative so it
was actually not so comfortable because
i was the one getting low on time and i
had to calculate the right way but it
looks like i kind of managed
did you tell him you're from brooklyn
and we don't get out hustled
yeah i guess well i mean it was but but
the thing is i've played him so many
games online anyway that i'm used to but
here at least i have a 30 second
increment so i
not gonna get just flagged
you got to be feeling good about how
you're doing at the moment going to the
rest day no absolutely yeah i mean i'm
happy with the way i'm playing i think
i'm
yesterday was kind of a non-game i
didn't get too much opportunities i
guess i didn't expect so much that
wesley would play that particular line
uh okay there's so many other things i
had to prepare for so maybe if i would
have known i would have tried something
different but yeah all in all i uh i'm
doing my best not perfect of course but
you know i have to just
keep trying to improve every game and
see what happens yeah i don't think
anybody in this tournament thinks that
they're doing perfectly well so far very
solid great result keep it up thank you
so much very well done indeed by the way
um i uh
is it okay if i show quickly there is
one moment i wanted to show from the
dominguez game if that's okay
all right which is round one yes yeah
there was this one moment that i thought
i going to need more persistence
some assistance let's see if we can get
this played
round one yeah yes perfect while you're
doing that by the way i know you're
really great friends with arena crush
you've got to be a
feeling for her what happened today
yeah i it looked like something went
wrong in the opening like somehow i
didn't like her position very quickly
and then i saw that i guess she
blundered this rook d4 move but i guess
her position was already kind of so-so
um wasn't that bad it wasn't that bad
yeah i mean it's it's tough but uh yeah
hopefully she'll she can recover and
obviously to lose a game like that
against the one of the main competitors
is is tough but it's even worse if you
lose a winning position let's say or
draw a winning position so i mean and
you know you kind of get a half rest day
so no of course it's not a
solace or anything like that but you
know it's
it's it's yeah it's it's obviously tough
but um she's a she has a very strong
character i'm sure she'll bounce back
fine and uh she'll be able to continue
battle and hopefully that will be enough
to fight for first seven rounds to go
definitely a lot of time left do we have
the position yes we do
yeah i i assume oh this game oh my
goodness yeah so we loved your position
yeah so here's the thing the computer
really loves you right yeah so here's
the thing so um i made a instructive
rookie mistake so here i spent 20
minutes or something like that because i
have so many options i can play 95 i can
play d6 i can play i was thinking queen
c4 right away and i didn't like b5 and
then i settled on d6 with the idea of
queen c4 right and i kind of
automatically always think queen c4
because i thought if i go bishop h4 so
the the move that was winning bishop h4
i thought he'll play rook e8
um and the point is after 95 knight d7
i can play a four and somehow this idea
just never occurred to me that this will
be so good like i was only looking at
bishop h4 with the idea of taking an f6
but this turned out to be something just
super amazing and if i would have maybe
stopped and think that that's what i
mean by it i didn't have enough over the
board practice maybe and i was making
rookie mistakes like even if you have a
long think it's good to double double
check maybe you have something better
and in this case you know queen c4 was
of course a good move but
it blew some of my advantage and then of
course i missed his move queen a6 just
completely flat out missed it and you
know after that it was already an end
game which he just defended really well
but i you know that's i just kind of
wanted to explain to my fans why didn't
gobish page four it was because rookie
897 this beautiful idea he's unpinning
but somehow i'm still completely winning
and to realize that it's just so good
and better way better than everything
else you know that's where you know i
guess the difference is between me and
the computer and
you know between any human and the
computer so
right we remember this game this
definitely was a great opportunity for
you but it seems like you bounced back
and doing quite well so well i always
believe in bouncing but bouncing back i
mean i this this is a tournament i knew
that there's going to be
a lot of missed opportunities because
people are very very resilient people
defend really well and so it's i knew
that it's not going to be just perfect
11 rounds i didn't expect that i'm not
going to let's say miss a win at some
point or blow a draw or lose the game
you know so i i prepared myself mentally
that i'll just have to you know
uh
weather the storm whatever comes at me
just
be
be really well prepared to continue
playing as if nothing happened and i
think that's the only way you can do in
such a tournament there's you know
because you don't really want to
collapse right so absolutely wise words
indeed now you get to rest we'll see you
in a couple of days yeah thank you
thanks for having me keep the optimism
alive there alex absolutely we do have a